aaa expects most of us to actually stay
home for the holiday
christmas travel will be down quite a
bit because of the coronavirus
in fact the centers for disease control
wants us to stay home to try and slow
the spread
hector mejia live this morning from
mccarran airport with the details
merry christmas eve to you hector
merry christmas eve john and we're
standing outside what seems to be
the vip christmas eve entrance we've
seen pilots and flight attendants here
walking across this parking lot and
making their way inside
the airport is reminding people that the
experience will obviously be different
than previous years with airlines having
a number of coveted safety rules
and the airport increasing its cleaning
and sanitizing procedures
according to aaa at least three quarters
of travelers are
choosing to stay home this holiday
season that means 34 million fewer
people compared to 2019
despite that drop though as many as 84.5
million americans are getting out anyway
between now and january third
but the cdc as we've been telling you is
telling people to stay home
aaa says most are getting around by car
with road trips making up
96 of holiday travel this year
in the mountain west region which
includes nevada 264
000 people are expected to get on a
plane
when we look at air travel we expect
about 2.9 million people
packing in the airports which will be a
60 drop in travel
meaning 4 million fewer travelers than
we saw in 2019
and 2020 also ends the 11th consecutive
year of holiday travel
growth it was just last year when triple
a expected more people than ever on
record
rushing home for the year and
celebrations and if you are flying
mccarran has a few refreshers safety
tips for you to stay safe during the
pandemic
we'll go over those tips still ahead in
the next half hour
reporting live outside mccarran airport
hector mejia 8 news now merry christmas
eve
thank you hector it would be certainly a
last minute trip if people are flying
out this morning but it is still
possible to be sure